i don't worry about the rest of it you
just don't worry about the rest of
that's crazy because i talked to a lot
of actors before and
you know they're just like oh yeah
you're working with de niro or something
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm working with de
niro and it gets in your head but you
what was your first big movie where
you're working with a lot of big stars
um
contact contact you're working with jody
foster
working with chelty matthew mcconaughey
yeah who started he was beginning the
rise of his career right yes
and and not at all you weren't nervous
working with jodie foster with justin
justin occurred you're there to do a
part that was what you did
well the interesting thing about contact
was that i
one of my favorite movies first film
mine too
and and not dated
no we're at all thing with the father at
the end still makes me cry come on it
did
they download her and give her the image
of something so they can talk to her and
it's in the image of her dad i mean
that's just like
unbelievable incredible first film i did
was the underneath this little indie
film with steven soderbergh
um
you like that you hear that yeah it's my
cuckoo clock i should have turned it off
yeah i like it but go ahead soderbergh
uh i worked on this
film called virtuosity uh
where where i learned that uh uh
they cut 80 of what i did in the film
was denzel and
russell crowe and uh they cut 80 of what
i did out of the movie and it was really
great because it was my second film and
i learned right then and there then the
next thing
that i got was heat
and i remember my agent calling and said
this is a big
pacino de niro film it's it's a small
role of uh of a role called van zant
and i read it and i said i'm in he goes
it's not big and i said no but it's five
scenes and you can't cut him out of the
movie
because i learned what virtuosity i was
it was you know what what has to be in
the movie to tell the story i was inco
it was inconsequential to the story the
part that i played in virtuosity yeah
heat
very consequential and i still to this
day
can read something and go
you don't need that role in the film
um
and it sometimes can make a decision
whether
you know to go with it or not um
but uh
then i did this thing called the albino
alligator yeah uh kevin's face
yeah faye dunaway and matt dillon yeah
gary sinise
so i played a couple of
tougher guys and then
i remember at the time back then and
thinking
i i wanted i gotta i want to switch it
up i want i want to do something else
and i didn't work for eight or nine
months and then i was living in new york
and my agent said listen there's this
really cool film with jodie foster and
they're called contact but they're not
letting the script out so if you want to
read it there's a part of this
astrophysicist you know
who is blind and if you want to if you
want to read it you have to do it at the
casting director's office
on melrose so people's express was
happening at the time
i got a ticket and i came out
read it in the office put myself you
know went on tape
got on a plane went back to new york i
was back like a day or two
and then
robert zemeckis saw it and then they
flew me back to
meet on it and it was me and a few other
people in uh and
it was like a month later and i ended up
getting it
and that was a that was a huge thing and
huge because it really shifted gears for
me
you